what is up guys I'm David Ahmadi here
with Jordan remai hello hello we're here
to break down the awesome new trailer
that just dropped for Star Wars Jedi
fallen order you've had a chance to go
really deep into this trailer and write
an article on all the things that you've
noticed yeah of course I always love to
display my Star Wars knowledge for
everyone else few chances that I have so
why don't you start with what you notice
that stood out from the trailer the most
well grabbed your attention about this
trailer I think the thing that grabbed
me most about this trailer is that it
kind of focuses on the second sister
which is the main antagonist for Jedi
fallen order we haven't really been able
to see much of her in previous trailers
and teasers and whatnot and she doesn't
factor very much in the comics at all so
we don't know much about her but she
talks a lot in this trailer we see her
fight against kal a few times in this
trailer and she's really aggressive and
kind of terrifying in a way she kind of
like just chases after kal with like
this primal ferocity curious to see if
what we see in this trailer translates
then into the game itself for sure
because in the past - it seems like we
haven't really gotten a good glimpse at
a property antagonist it seemed to be
mostly focusing on kal itself you know
from like III trailers and gameplay
trailers and things like that so is
there anything else that kind of stood
out to you yeah so we actually get to
see some of the locations that kal is
going to visit we kind of see this like
hologram galaxy map that shows four
different planets and it's difficult to
tell which planet is which because
there's no names attached to it but we
do see like actual like close-up
cinematics of each of the planets there
is an ice one there's a marshy one
there's one that kind of looks
industrialized and stuff like that so we
don't really know what these planets are
but they do seem distinct and they seem
like they're pretty fun to explore I'm
excited to see if any of them are
current planets in the Star Wars
universe like the ice one it very well
could be Hoth and it would be awesome to
see the planet that featured so
prominently in Empire Strikes Back like
what it was like 20-30 years before that
movie what it looked like it probably
looks exactly the same it's just a giant
ball of ice so there's the marsh planet
that you mentioned and there seems to be
this like
Jedi Temple these ruins you know what
kind of can you what can you say about
that yes so we're not really sure what
these ruins are like you said before it
looks like a Jedi Temple like Cal needs
to use the force to open it inside you
see murals on the walls of these robed
figures there's these puzzles that Cal
is solving by like using the force to
move these large blocks together in
certain ways and there's even like a
symbol of like the old Jedi Order on one
of the walls that Callos like dust off
to see so it's tied to the Jedi Order
but we don't really know why Cal is
there we don't really know what he's
looking for there's also this like
really creepy moment like as he's like
opening the door walking through a
tunnel and that brief second of that
fade to black and briefly here like a
Darth Vader breathing sound and so it's
like his Darth Vader here is this a
vision it's like this really creepy
intriguing thing that maybe Cal is
visiting this like Jedi Temple to get
knowledge or something like that and
maybe experiences a vision about Vader
or something like that or maybe even
like meets Vader in some capacity and we
don't know because it flashes through
all these things so quickly were there
any new enemies or was there anything
interesting that you saw in this new
trailer here that relates to the enemies
you're going to be fighting in combat
yeah so one of the cool aspects about
the purge troopers which Phil wrote a
really cool feature about how these
these stormtroopers that are kind of
trained to hunt Jedi and all the
previous trailers we've seen them use
these electro staffs that general
Grievous's Magna guards used to kind of
help them fight Jedi but respawn has
told us in the past that there are other
variations of these purge troopers and
now we finally get to see a few of them
in this trailer like there's one near
the beginning that's carrying this like
giant axe that he kind of uses that's a
lot slower but it looks like it packs a
bit more of a punch we see one that's
like a little bit more nimble and
carrying these two twin blades and we
even see some that are just carrying
standard rifles and so we don't really
get to see much of them in combat but
respawn has said that they each behave
very differently so it'll be interesting
to see how these different types are
able to respond to the powers that Cal
has and I think more importantly we find
get to see what lightsaber combat kind
of looks like because we actually near
the end of the trailer get to see kal
fighting against second sister and she's
wielding a lightsaber so for like a
brief snippet we see the what lightsaber
combat looks like and it looks hard like
like she is attacking you with this
ferocious like ferocity that like and
he's just like barely deflecting her
blows and so like they wanna hang in
there I think so like maybe this is near
the beginning of the game where you
don't have many like powers and you're
not really sure what to do maybe it goes
a little bit slower when you're actually
playing the game but that looks fat it
doesn't look it looks fast it looks
really really fast I mean yeah just
somersaulting and doing these flips it
looks very high octane yeah so I'm
looking forward to seeing how that
actually feels like an action where I
actually have the control in my hand I'm
going through that moment just looking
at the trailer I'm excited totally I
think another thing that we can talk
about this seems to be these like
creatures I'm noticing this huge like
giant beast yeah have you seen those
before
thing that's really intriguing it's the
giant bat yeah I have no idea what it
could possibly be we've seen like
bat-like creatures in Star Wars before
but they've all been like our bats like
small in size like usually no bigger
than like a human being just like dragon
bat yeah like this is huge like at one
moment Cal is like riding on its back
yes it's like trying to fight him off
and I'm like wow what what is this thing
I have claimed this bad dragon is mine
but it is cool to kind of like see that
we're not going to just have like these
kind of careful management fights where
you're trying to like deflect enemy
attacks and then kind of maneuver into
new space there's are there are going to
be these like giant battles that we saw
in games like The Force Unleashed where
you're taking on these like huge
monstrous foes like this giant bat
creature that I assume like you're just
gonna have to like slowly slash away at
like over a period of time before you
finally take it down so that's the
latest trailer for Star Wars Jedi fallen
order what other moments are things did
you notice in the trailer let us know in
the comments below thanks for watching
guys
[Music]
[Music]
you